hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
i'm a property investor and
right now is a very good opportunity to
find bargain property investment so
in this video i'm going to be giving you
the five steps
to finding a bargain property now even
if you have no money it doesn't matter
because if you can find a house that's
worth two hundred thousand pounds
and you can negotiate down to 150 000
pounds
that's a 50 000 pound discount you could
pass that on to an investor
for a 5 000 fee the key is
as a property entrepreneur as a property
investor is you need to be finding deals
and right now deals are on the table
520 000 properties were paused from
being sold
during lockdown lockdown is now over as
far as property investing is concerned
estate agents are open viewings are
going ahead
and there are juicy deals on the table
so what i want you to do
is get a pen get a piece of paper take
good notes on this video
and then actually implement what i say i
started property investing when i was 17
years old from a working class family
home
25 years old i was a millionaire i'm now
29 years old i'm a multi-property
millionaire and i'm sharing with you the
five steps that you can find property
investments so get a pen
get a paper smash subscribe turn the
notification bell on
and that's all i ask like the video drop
a comment that's it because the more you
comment the more you
like the more people will see this video
and people need to see this video
step number one write this down is you
need to
qualify qualify qualify qualify
as a property bargain hunter what do i
mean by qualify you need to number one
qualify the sellers so before you start
viewing houses don't just start
viewing houses for the sake of it and
putting forward stupid offers
you've got to speak to them beforehand
and make sure that they are
motivated you've got to qualify them
you've got to qualify the agent you've
got to put forward some if would offers
listen i'm a property investor if i was
to offer 80
market value would that be something
that your client would be interested or
open to
so qualify that they're motivated you
cannot be
a motivated buyer you have to be dealing
with motivated sellers
so qualify them and also if you're able
to if you've got cash in your bank
qualify yourself show the estate agent
your proof of deposit
show them your funds show them your
solicitor details
qualify them qualify you it saves a lot
of time and it means that you're going
to be putting yourself in the right
place at the right time
number two is don't speak first when
you're at the viewing
just listen listen to their problems
listen to what their story is listen to
how long they've been trying to sell
why they're trying to sell your job is
to be detective investigator
and find their situation listen don't
speak first and when you speak usually
speak with questions
don't speak first and don't put forward
the offer first
ask them what they'll accept so many
times
i've had situations whereby there's been
a house on the market for a 200 000
pound
i've offered an offer i've put forward
an offer of 180 i thought 20 grand
discount that'd be great
they say yes i'm like
what would have happened if i'd said
160. so don't put forward the offer
first let them speak first
ask them this this is the magic question
you want to say if i was to buy the
property cash tomorrow
what would be the lowest you'd be able
to accept and still live with
that's the question that's the magic
question so write that down did you
notice that was another if would
offer if i was to buy the property cash
tomorrow
what would the lowest you'd be able to
accept with and still live with me like
that's the kind of question you need to
be so don't speak first
listen make them put forward the offer
number three
write this down is expect to be rejected
if you want to be successful in property
if you want to find some
cracking deals you're gonna get some
rejection first you're gonna get a state
agent saying that's too cheeky
you're gonna get the seller saying how
dare you offer that expect it
in britain we are far too polite
we don't like to hear the words no we we
hear no
and it ruins our day expect to hear it
and
don't take it personally if you're not
embarrassed about your offer
the offer is too high so
be embarrassed prepare yourself to be
rejected that's part of the fun
it's like when you're haggling at the
marketplace you're walking around
you're trying to haggle that's how it
goes same
with property property investment is one
of the very strange things where when
you buy a house
you can just decide between you and the
buyer what you buy the house for
you can't do that with bitcoin you can't
do stocks and shares or gold the price
is the price
make the most and take advantage of
being able to negotiate the price and
expect to be told no and stop being so
british with your politeness step four
please
write this down and if you're enjoying
the video please do smash the like
button drop a comment step four
justify everything when you do finally
put forward your offer you've got to
justify it don't just say
150 you've got to justify it
and be specific as well with your offer
that's a whole nother video of how to
work out what you offer but you've got
to justify why you offer what you offer
if you say 150 and it's worth 200 you
need to say 150 because
lockdowns just happened there's a lot
for sale right now because
the one a few doors down the road sold
for 150
because it needs work doing to it you
need to just give all the reasons
as to why you're offering lower number
one it'll make them much more likely to
say yes
number two is in business whenever you
put forward an offer wherever you do
anything you've got to justify it even
if you skip a queue you can't just skip
a queue you've got to give a reason why
you're skipping the queue
write it down justify everything number
five lastly
turn a no into a yes when you're told no
which you need to expect because you're
going to get rejected
don't take it personally but also don't
accept that that is a forever no
when someone tells me no oh i don't hear
no i hear
not for now you've got to follow up
call them back a week later hey i know i
offered you 150 000 pounds on your
property
it's now been a week how's it going
follow follow up
when the estate agent says oh no way
would my client accept 150 000 pounds
you need to say
fair enough completely understand have
you got any other
property owners that are a little bit
more motivated
so when you get a no think of how you
can turn it into another opportunity or
into a yes
folks there are the five steps don't
keep watching me on youtube
go view some houses there's incredible
deals out there
go get some deals sell some deals
package some deals
buy some deals that's what makes me
excited most of my content on my youtube
channel
is not me talking it's me pulling people
like you
onto youtube and interviewing your
success as a result of listening to me
on youtube and going on my training
if you want me to mentor you as well if
you want to be mentored in property
i've got a whole team of mentors check
the description
in the link below and you can see how
you can get further training
but don't even do that just go and view
some houses and get some deals
thanks so much for watching peace out
see you next time